tre anni fa per la prima volta mi sono
ritrovato a vedere un video di ragazzini
di 14 anni che si trapana vano la
mandibola vari punti strategici per
renderla più maschile è più dura sempre
tre anni fa ho letto per la prima volta
la parola canta al tilt e mi hanno
hackerato tutti i profili social subito
dopo perché per la prima volta tre anni
fa sono entrata in contatto con un in
sen chi sono gli zen so se qualcuno di
voi lo sa ma sono i cieli pin volontari
sono vergini per colpa delle donne che
non li vogliono perché sono brutti
quindi un gruppo di maschi eterosessuali
che costruisce la propria identità sul
fatto di non riuscire a fare sesso con
una donna
ci sono tre gradi di celibato il primo è
quello base quindi non riuscire a fare
sesso come non hanno mai fatto sesso con
una donna e magari qualcuno di voi si
trova in questa categoria per scelta per
età per qualche motivo particolare
poi c'è una seconda categoria che sono
quelli che non hanno mai baciato una
donna equa e più difficile che qualcuno
di voi possa appartenere a questa
categoria è la terza che la più triste
di tutte è sono quelli poverini che non
sono mai stati abbracciati da una donna
quindi a cles kiss l'ex bergen e qua
vedo l'ora impossibile che qualcuno di
voi non abbia provato l'ebbrezza di
essere abbracciato da una donna quindi
linsel sono questi è un fenomeno è
importante dire che nasce online nasce e
si sviluppa online quindi in assenza di
contatto diretto fra di loro si parlano
sui forum nelle chat private telegram
poi i forum vengono chiusi ogni tre mesi
quindi ne creano altri hanno anche nel
dark web qualche volta io mi sono
infiltrata in queste chat e in questi
forum per qualche mese per scrivere un
articolo su di loro
lo scritto si sono arrabbiati tantissimo
perché comunque tre anni fa ancora non
se ne parlava molto in italia e sono
arrabbiati è signora piedi soprattutto
non tanto per i contenuti dell'articolo
che papà l'avesse scritto un maschio
sarebbe stato meglio però non erano era
quello il punto ma perché io sono una
donna quindi per loro sono satana in
qualche modo e in più sono una donna
secondo loro
in più quindi sono decente sono bruciò
fredda sui loro forum loro loro vanno
dalla mattina alla sera danno voti a se
stessi e agli altri quindi sono voti su
alex mucci se anche tu votata o chiunque
a voti molto severi sono severissimi
quindi hanno fatto una scheda su di me
hanno preso tutte le mie foto su
facebook su instagram a ma guarda qui
c'è una grinza la cellulite vi hanno
fatto un pochino lo scanner emendato
sente più quindi detto la pa è carina è
una donna quindi e potente quindi nel
mercato del sesso e della seduzione loro
chiamano così il mercato del sesso se è
una persona potente che può scegliere il
proprio partner sessuale e lo sceglierà
sicuramente bello ricco di successo non
certo uno di noi quindi è il nemico
quindi questa è un po la il quadro
iniziale per dire che gli inseriscono
effettivamente un fenomeno sociale in
crescita in ascesa cioè
un canone sociale che si inserisce fra
il ti pago la cena o non ti pago la cena
fra il mi va bene se mi aprì lo
sportello della macchina ma non voglio
che curi la barba o ti curi le
sopracciglia va dall estetista quindi
fra quella che loro chiamano la crisi
del maschio contemporaneo che è poverino
stanno più come comportarsi con le donne
è l'avvento dei nuovi femminismi quindi
un cambiamento e ruoli di genere che in
qualche modo ne dica che la struttura
sociale cambia l'ideologia sta cambiando
però esistono delle sacche delle ferite
online dove le persone che sono in
dissenso a quali non vanno bene queste
cose si raggruppano è piano piano fanno
gruppo e diventano sempre più grandi e
potenti di crescita perché tre anni fa
come ho detto nessuno sapeva chi fosse
che il cell qui in italia che nascono in
america come fenomeno i forum insel in
italia dal 2008 2009 sono attivi e
invece adesso se tu scrivi qualcosa di
vagamente bisò gino su internet twitter
immediatamente qualcuno ti dirà se anche
qui in italia quindi il termine piano
piano sta diventando un po po abbastanza
mainstream
e vi faccio una domanda faccio una
domanda le donne in platea per iniziare
proprio entrare di più questo questo
fenomeno
intanto voglio dire che odiano le donne
ma odiano anche gli uomini quindi
vogliono tutti italia non si c è nessuno
si salva odiano le donne e odiano anche
le donne che entrano i loro forum perchè
ci sono anche delle donne che fanno
parte di questi forum sembra assurdo ma
anche se loro sono episodi né odio le
donne tutti i loro boss sono contro le
donne ci sono le donne delle donne che
magari non si trovano a loro agio con il
loro corpo che entrano le loro forum
cercano di parlare con loro comunque di
creare empatia da loro dolore trattano
male tutto il tempo le chiamano cio cs
obese per farvi capire la delicatezza
e quindi odiano le donne ovviamente
belle odio le donne brutte modi anche
gli uomini belli ovviamente vogliono gli
uomini belli gli uomini alfa gli uomini
che riescono appunto a fare sesso e
perché perché riescono a fare sesso
riescono a fare sesso perché hanno tre
centimetri di ossa in più questa è la
frase che su tutti forum domina cioè tre
centimetri di ossa in più che vuol dire
questa cosa vuol dire lo capiamo ho
detto già entriamo un po di più in
profondità nel fenomeno allora ho già
detto dei termini un po strani cantal
tilt in ciad rap il bug amare i per
chiamare sono i termini un po pò strani
che non iniziato non riesce a capire se
io vi dico adesso scrivete su google il
forum dei brutti perché il forum più
popolare qui in italia dell'its el poi
leggete un post dread e magari capite il
40 50 per cento di quello che leggete
perché potranno un loro linguaggio
specifico una loro ideologia ben
definita una filosofia possiamo dire che
è molto forte
e questi forum cosa parti cosa parlano
parlano di donne ovviamente è della loro
bruttezza subita quindi questi sono i
due temi principali leggerli sembra un
po a leggere un femminile degli anni 50
perché scrivono so come faccio eliminare
putin come faccio a farmi una foto non
si vede si vede la mia pancia non si
vede la mia patria una specie di
continuo a tutti alla ricerca di
aiutatemi a capire come posso essere più
bello questo è il centro principale poi
ovviamente odio a profusione per le
donne è la domanda principale che fanno
e questa voi donne e la loro risposta la
sua vela tivo però voglio farla voi voi
donne andreste mai a cena anche sulla
cera fareste mai sesso con un nuovo
brutto
senza soldi e senza una posizione
sociale cioè senza un talento ok ok
queste sono le tre le tre
caratteristiche principali quindi look
mani e status se tu non hai nessuna di
queste tre caratteristiche secondo loro
non puoi vivere una vita triste è fatta
di rifiuti questa è la loro la loro idea
esistono degli uomini brutti che hanno
donne si è vero woody allen cairo mazzi
loro dico saprò mazzi e brutto però fa
sesso però alle donne perché a due delle
tre caratteristiche ansoldi ea status
però un uomo senza soldi brutto senza
status è un in sé è un brutto sfigato e
non avrà nessuna questa è la red bull è
la base della rugby quindi se voi non
credete in questo se voi dite no non è
vero basta fate ridere le donne ma no
non è vero leggi libri sarà interessante
qualcuno ti vorrà ti dicono sei nel
mondo dei mini pony assolutamente falso
sei un blu pilato come matrix quando il
protagonista deve prendere la pillola
azzurra ora pillola rossa pilot
l'azzurra rimanere l'ignoranza la
pillola rossa sai che cosa è la realtà e
la realtà e cattiva ed è questa di noi
vivremo una vita orrenda
fra le tre caratteristiche che ho
elencato quella che li fa più arrabbiare
e la bruttezza
perché mentre i soldi e successo piano
piano e la vita di cui fare ora dipende
da te la bruttezza è un marchio
originario che ha 11 stico è tutto e sei
brutto nella colpa originaria naturale
quindi loro sono sono soprattutto
incentrati sulla buttata si arrabbiano
perché sono brutti e questa bruttezza
può essere migliorata solamente dalla
chirurgia estetica quindi loro guru
massimi sono i chirurghi estetici fra
loro sono in fissa con qualsiasi ce la
fanno i nomi di tutti i chirurghi del
mondo e discutono in continuazione di
quante operazioni posso farmi come quel
chirurgo è bravo dei voti e quindi
il chirurgo e come una specie di dio no
che ti può cambiare i connotati e fare
diventare degli uomini appunto attraenti
per le donne per farli rientrare in
questo mercato del sesso
è però spoiler non succede mai loro
continuano a farsi operazioni in cui
arrivano mai alla quadra infatti il
sogno erotico proibito di un insel e
farsi questo lefort ea una operazione
pazzesca che non fanno in nessun posto
in italia ne vanno all'estero a farlo è
un cliente ti tolgono tutte le ossa
della faccia e tele ritiri montano la
faccia di un altro modo di una
giornalista del new york times fatto un
bellissimo perso andando a
intervistare questo guru della chirurgia
americana che è pratica questo lefort
el'articolo titolava quante ero possa
devo rompermi per riuscire a fare sesso
può parlare dell'inter e
quindi dicevamo la red bull
tu puoi prendere la red bull quindi
sapere che la realtà è questa
e però non eliminare donne dalla tua
vita quindi continuare a desiderarle
fare andare dal chirurgo estetico andare
in palestra a prendere gli steroidi
a seguire dei guru della seduzione che
ti dicono come riuscire ad approcciare
una donna puoi fare tutte queste cose
oppure ci sono degli insert che invece
prendono la pillola nera e la pillola
nera è un po una filosofia della morte
perché è una
eliminazione del tutto delle donne della
tua vita la eliminò sono da solo mi
richiudo in casa non guardo più nemmeno
film con le donne non mi masturbo più
alcuni ricordano la castrazione chimica
insomma è una reclusione monacale in
casa il caso comunque vediamo solo
vedono solo maschi eccetera
e questo è il porta molto spesso ha
portato molto spesso a violenza casi di
violenza perché in america in sel hanno
firmato varie stragi la prima nel 2014
quando agli hot roger un ragazzo di 22
anni entra campus suo campus santa
barbara e ammazza sei persone e ne
ferisce 14 e poi si uccide la sua
mercedes nera o poco dopo giorno prima
aveva fatto un video su youtube diceva
io sono vergine per colpa vostra
tale eccetera eccetera
ed è solo minimamente
noi hanno gli ha dato retta il giorno
dopo ho fatto questa cosa e lui è una
specie di santone per l'inps e perché
comunque scrive anche a memoir volto lui
di 200 pagine dove parla di che cosa che
significa salò in sel quindi un po il
guru il primo in sel veramente
teorizzato dopo di lui ci sono state
tantissime altre stragi in america anche
nel regno unito è nell'ultimo anno sono
intensificate moltissimo nonostante la
pandemia
quindi perché parla oggi di questo
fenomeno
lo strano perché non è solo nell unico
sono tantissimi gruppi online che piano
piano si radicalizzano su internet da
piccolissimi diventano giganti e poi
entrano nella nostra realtà no prima
delle stragi nessuno sapeva incontro
linselles però da anni si fomentavano si
radicalizza vano su internet no ma la
stessa cosa con i co a non prima del
dello sciamano pazzo che è entrato a
capitol hill durante durante la pandemia
che abbiamo visto su tutte le bacheche
di facebook nessuno si chiedeva chi
fossero questi non è pure sono persone
sono tantissime milioni di persone e
ogni giorno scrivono e portano dissenso
rivolta in giro per rita cioè prima era
facile capire chi erano i gruppi in
rivolta no viene mente la brigade
brigate rosse tosano gruppi organizzati
abbastanza evidenti adesso vi se tutti
questi gruppi sono sotto cioè su
internet se qualcuno non li guarda
finché poi non entrano di prepotenza
nella nostra vita non ne sappiamo niente
quindi secondo me è importante
conoscerli dall'inizio cercare di
entrare in contatto via verdi creare un
dialogo pubblico su questi ncell su
questi creano su tutti quanti gruppi che
esistono online è cercare punto anche di
farsi un autocritica perché no io ho
provato a farlo e dopo l'articolo sono
arrabbiati o caiano minacciata hanno mai
dato dei regalini molto molto carini in
redazione al giornale ora non vi so dire
perché vi terreste e quindi ho deciso di
scrivere un secondo articolo meno da
entomologa appunto che osserva il
fenomeno e modo ideologico ma entrando
in contatto con loro quindi ci ho
parlato
sono andato a cena con uno di loro
è questo ragazzo era effettivamente un
insel black piller quindi onyx el della
peggior specie castrato chimicamente è
venuto però a cena con me l'occhio
abbracciato quindi non è più a glass per
gene e siamo stati comunque due ore
seduti nel servito a niente è servito a
nulla c'è nessuno dei due ha cambiato
minimamente idea opposizione però se
usati due ore li siamo guardati qualche
gesto qualche parola detta male
e uscito fuori il motivo un po di un in
conversazione anche violenta aggressiva
che la vicinanza che c'è in ogni caso
tra due esseri umani
[Applauso]